le maire de gênes l'art vient de
récupérer les clés du musée chez un
huissier la liquidation était prononcée
l'inventaire a été fait le conseil
municipal peut donc commencer à
travailler sur l'avenir de cette
structure
c'est en 2006 que fut inaugurée ce
centre d'interprétation de la ligne de
démarcation
le projet était séduisant de l'armistice
jusqu'à fin 44 génelard comme d'autres
communes de saône et loire a été coupée
en deux par cette ligne qui n'avait rien
de fictif beaucoup payèrent de leur vie
d'avoir tenté de la passer
clandestinement des familles étaient
séparés des passeurs faciliter le
franchissement
bref cette frontière bouleversa la vie
des gens et aujourd'hui encore cette
histoire intéresse sur les années de
fonctionnement correct y avait environ
4000 visiteurs par an j'ai effectivement
un intérêt réel puisqu'on a toujours des
personnes qui y prennent contact avec la
mairie qui sont un peu déçus d'ailleurs
de d'avoir trouvé porte close et donc je
pense que on peut re développer
effectivement un intérêt à ce centre
nous n'avons pu joindre jean michel
chantreau qui fut l'initiateur du centre
et présidait l'association qui gérait ce
lieu mais il semble que la gestion du
musée n'a pas été à la hauteur de
l'intérêt du projet les comptes étaient
dans le rouge depuis quatre ans et le
maire de génelard souhaite tirer les
leçons de cette mésaventure s'est
compliqué la vie associative à l'heure
d'aujourd'hui les financements ne sont
plus aussi présent que par le passé donc
c'est effectivement compliqué le les
seuls qui peuvent gérer des structures
de ce type ce sont les collectivités
le musée faisait partie de la panoplie
touristique de cette petite commune de
15 cents habitants traversée par le
canal du centre
sa fermeture change la donne à la fin de
cette semaine on va inaugurer maison
éclusière qui est transformée en gîte
est donc cette stratégie elle avait été
monté à l'origine avec comme point de
baies de départ le centre
d'interprétation rouvrir ce musée sur
d'autres bases voilà donc l'objectif de
la mary jane